pinned to the ground a terrorist suspect
a Taser pointed but not fired
this was outside Manchester's biggest
shopping center police use cable ties to
restrain the 41 year old male suspect
before leading him away inside the
Arndale Centre terrified shoppers were
locked into stores whilst armed police
sealed the area and medics helped the
injured the girl stood there dear a pin
or scarf around her arm was shouting
someone's been stabbed
I was looking thinking dead confused
thinking a carpet ruler fortune automata
fell and she was stood up in the next
moon fell off floor and then that's when
I said my lord a broad on the floor just
heard they're like people they just
scream in like I don't know like just
few seconds and then like when I was
going to see what's happened I'm still
on the fearful like they were inside and
they start like running and going
outside five people were hurt three had
been stabbed they're in a stable
condition within hours police confirm
the suspect had been arrested on
suspicion of a terror offense he was
armed with a large knife and as he
entered exchange Court he began lunging
and attacking people with the knife we
do not know the motivation for this
terrible attack it was random it's
certainly brutal and of course extremely
frightening for anyone who witnessed it
frightening especially for a city like
Manchester where memories of terrorism
are still so painful this wheel of
Manchester sign was put up after the
2017 Manchester Arena attack and there
is a real poignancy to the fact that it
is just meters away from new police tape
a new police crime scene after this
seemingly random attack feegan Murray's
son Martin was one of the 22 people that
died in the Manchester Arena bomb today
has shown they really have stepped up
their game you know the the Armed Health
Centre responded mega quickly the
emergency services were there in no time
and that's really impressive and and so
reassuring really
Manchester is now under watch police say
the suspect acted alone and is from the
city a city that is being searched to
understand what happened